une rencontre virtuelle avec edward
snowdon l'occasion pour lui d'être
invité dans le débat sur le projet de
loi antiterroriste ses 51
selon lui c'est en quelque sorte une
imitation du pétrole et attaques
américaines
cette loi de surveillance pour lutter
contre le terrorisme avait été adopté
dans l'urgence
quelques semaines après les attentats du
11 septembre une pente dangereuse pour
le canada où les services de
renseignement sont parmi les moins bien
surveillé en occident dit il edward
snowdon qui a rendu public des détails
confidentiels sur des programmes des
côtes électronique américain se montre
toutefois prudent et ne prétends pas
être un expert sur ses 51 de chance il
se permet d'accuser le gouvernement
fédéral de créer de toutes pièces une
menace à la sécurité nationale qui
n'existe pas le terrorisme du moins
claire faudra rappelle-t-il wynnchurch -
cherche crois oui il y aura des crimes
monstrueux à l'occasion admet-il mais il
faut quand même protéger les libertés et
les droits individuels selon lui depuis
des années et doit le no2 critique la
surveillance de masques adoptent de plus
en plus le gouvernement
il est convaincu qu'elle est intrusive
et qu'elle ne permet pas de prévenir des
attaques de loups solitaires
il croit plutôt qu'elle donne aux
gouvernements trop de pouvoirs des
pouvoirs comme ils n'en n'ont jamais eu
auparavant ici julian lamoureux radio
canada toronto